CONTROVERSIAL PROPOSALS.
MAKE NO MISTAKE, TEXAS IS NOW
POISED TO BE THE LARGEST STATE
KB
YET TO ENACT CHANGES THAT AMOUNT
TO VOTER SUPPRESSION AND AREN'T
NECESSARY.
>> THERE BEING 81 AYES --
>> Reporter: HOURS BEFORE
SUNRISE FRIDAY, TEXAS
REPUBLICANS ADVANCED LEGISLATION
IMPOSING NEW VOTING RESTRICTIONS
ON THE LONE STAR STATE.
THE NEW BILL LOWERS INITIALLY
PROPOSED CRIMINAL PENALTIES FOR
VOTING ERRORS, GIVES PARTISAN
POLL WATCHERS MORE POWER, BUT
MAKES IT EASIER TO REMOVE THEM
DISRUPTIONS AND BANS ELECTION
OFFICIALS FROM SENDING
UNSOLICITED ABSENTEE BALLOT
APPLICATIONS.
THE BILL'S LIKELY HEADED FOR
FINAL PASSAGE EARLY NEXT WEEK.
[ CHANTS ]
>> Reporter: PROTESTERS RALLIED
AS HOUSE LAWMAKERS DEBATED FOR
HOURS.
>> REFORMS ARE NEEDED TO ENSURE
THAT FRAUD DOES NOT UNDERMINE
THE PUBLIC CONFIDENCE.
>> IT'S GOING TO
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACT PEOPLE
OF COLOR.
YOU HAVE TO UNDERSTAND THE
DAMAGE YOU'RE CAUSING.
>> Reporter: REPUBLICANS CLAIM
THEIR PLAN WILL INCREASE
ELECTION SECURITY.
>> WHEN THIS BILL SEEKS TO DO IS
MAKE THEM SAFER.
>> Reporter: THE LEAD REPUBLICAN
SPONSOR STRUGGLED AT TIMES TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS ABOUT THE BILL.
>> WHAT FRAUD IS IT DESIGNED TO
STOP?
>> OKAY.
YEAH.
WELL, YOU KNOW, WE'VE GOT --
WE'RE TRYING TO MAYBE STOP THE
-- WE CALL BALLOT HARVESTING.
>> Reporter: DEMOCRATS SAY IT'S
VOTER SUPPRESSION ALL BASED ON A
FALSEHOOD.
>> IS THERE BILL SIMPLY A
CONTINUATION OF THE BIG LIE
PERPETRATED BY DONALD TRUMP THAT
SOMEHOW HE REALLY ACTUALLY WON
THE PRESIDENTIAL -- IS THAT
REALLY WHAT THIS IS ALL ABOUT?
>> NOT AT ALL.
THIS BILL IS NOT ABOUT THE
FORMER PRESIDENT.
>> I HAVE WHAT WE THINK IS THE
STRONGEST ELECTION INTEGRITY
MEASURES IN THE COUNTRY.
I'M GOING TO SIGN IT RIGHT HERE.
IT'S GOING TO TAKE EFFECT.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> Reporter: EARLIER THURSDAY IN
FLORIDA, REPUBLICAN GOVERNOR RON
DeSANTIS SIGNED A SIMILAR LAW AT
A BILL SIGNING AIRED LIVE ONLY
ON FOX NEWS.
THAT LAW LIMITS MAIL-IN VOTING,
RESTRICTS BALLOT DROP BOXES, AND
REQUIRES FLORIDIANS TO SHOW I.D.
FOR NEW MAIL-IN BALLOT REQUESTS.
PROMPTING SEVERAL LAWSUITS FROM
CIVIL RIGHTS ORGANIZATIONS
INCLUDING THE NAACP WHICH CALLED
THE NEW LAW A HORRIFYING
REMINDER AT THE FRAGILITY OF
DEMOCRACY.
SO FOR THOSE OF YOU KEEPING
SCORE AT HOME, FLORIDA HAS
PASSED ITS LAW, TEXAS IS ON THE
VERGE OF DOING SO.
AND NOW OHIO REPUBLICANS ARE OUT
WITH THEIR VERSIONS OF THIS
BILL.
IT WOULD LIMIT THE NUMBER OF
DROP BOXES, PUT MORE STRICT --
STRICTER REQUIREMENTS ON YOUR
ABSENTEE BALLOT APPLICATIONS,
AND REDUCE THE NUMBER OF EARLY
VOTING DAYS.
WHAT DO THESE STATES ALL HAVE IN
COMMON?
PREDOMINANTLY REPUBLICAN, EASILY
WON LAST YEAR BY FORMER
PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP, AND
WELL-RUN ELECTIONS WITH NO
WIDESPREAD EXAMPLES OF ANY OF
THE FRAUD REPUBLICANS ALLEGE
THEY'RE TRYING TO FIX.
GAYLE?
>> I KNOW.
IT SEEMS LIKE FIXING A PROBLEM
THAT DOESN'T EXIST.
DOESN'T IT?
>> Reporter: AND MOSTLY AT THE
REQUEST OF FORMER PRESIDENT
TRUMP WHO CONTINUES TO BELIEVE
FALSELY THAT THERE WERE PROBLEMS
WITH THESE ELECTIONS THAT NEED
TO BE ADDRESSED.
>> THE ISSUE IS THE VOTERS, THE
VOTERS THINK THIS PROBLEM IS
REAL.
AND SO THEIR ELECTED OFFICIALS
HAVE TO RESPOND TO A PROBLEM
THEY'VE TALKED ABOUT ENOUGH TO
HAVE TO NOW ACT ON.
>> WHEN IN FACT VIRTUALLY EVERY
COURT IN THE COUNTRY FOUND NO
WIDESPREAD VOTER FRAUD.
>> HERE WE ARE IN AMERICA WITH
THE WORLD'S OLDEST DEMOCRACY,
BUT WITH VOTING RATES WE'RE IN
THE MIDDLE OF THE PACK.
THIS COULD MAKE IT HARDER AND
SINK US FURTHER.
>> THAT'S WHY YOU HAVE TO DO
YOU'RE OWN DUE DILIGENCE AND
RESEARCH TO GET TO THE TRUTH.
YOU CAN'T CHANGE T